Prof: A student,
a former student of mine,
emailed me last night from Lake
Tahoe,
where they had received six
feet of snow in the past four
days.
Can you imagine that compared
to what seems like an
interesting day outside here?
The western storms are really
quite terrific this year.
If any of you are outdoor
enthusiasts.
So Mammoth Mountain in Southern
California received eight feet
of snow last week,
Squaw six, Jackson Hole between
six and seven.
It's really quite remarkable,
one storm after another is
pummeling the West Coast.
So today I want to continue and
conclude the discussion about
nuclear experimentation and have
you think a bit more with me
about guidelines for
experimentation and how those
might be embedded into law.
And I also want to start out by
having you consider the central
challenges that were faced by
the president,
the Defense Department,
and the Atomic Energy
Commission.
So that imagine yourself in the
position of trying to figure how
rapidly to develop the nuclear
testing program and how you
might guide it and what the
central purposes were.
So underlying the plan and the
research was really the need to
understand what our resilience
would be in the face of an
attack.
The construction of weaponry
that would be deliverable was
one problem,
but that was more of a
technical problem,
compared to wondering about how
we might survive an attack.
A central question associated
with that is how to minimize
human exposure for what periods
of time were necessary to
prevent long-term illness,
and how to decontaminate and
restore the environment.
Also how to convince the public
of the need for continued
testing as evidence kept leaking
out into the press in a variety
of ways,
but not in small part because
of the availability of detection
equipment.
So Geiger counters were not a
technology that was required to
be licensed or under the control
of the government.
Also, the x-ray film,
as I described,
being overexposed when it
arrived at hospitals led people
to understand that something was
going on.
They also faced the challenge
of how to maintain their
secrets.
And they established a very
large element within their
bureaucracy to work on different
processes to encourage workers
to change their behavior in a
way that would minimize the
opportunity for leaking of
secrets.
And then the central question
that we'll look at today is,
if you have a population that's
been seriously exposed,
how do you manage them?
How do you manage their
complaints?
What kind of provisions would
you make for them in terms of
long-term care or compensation?
So in example after example
among the 2,000 tests that were
conducted during this period,
you find workers and military
officials being intensely
exposed.
Those closest to the site
experienced the highest degrees
of radiation,
often without recognition of
what they'd experienced or
without understanding.
And something that was really
quite remarkable following the
test in the Bikini Atoll,
when you had a hundred ships
that were lined up encircling
the blast site was that almost
instantaneously,
they created a massive amount
of hazardous waste.
And they had no understanding
of what the implications might
be for dealing with that waste.
And if you step back and you
think about the location of the
testing site in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean,
they were very conscious of
what really has become a
fundamental principal of
managing the environment and
producing environmental quality,
which is the idea that dilution
is the solution to pollution.
So that the expectation that
the technological danger will
somehow dissipate as it moves
further and further away from
the point of release across
space and time to pose no danger
and eventually go away.
And one interesting idea behind
this idea,
behind the presumption that
pollution is just going to go
away is that it's pretty easy to
conclude that if you don't have
sensitive detection technology.
So if you can't see a
pollutant, you can't taste it,
you can't smell it,
you can't feel it,
if you don't have a
technologically sophisticated
surveillance system in place,
people presume that it's gone
away.
So gradually,
they realized that they needed
to understand this
distributional pattern more
carefully.
But the assumption was that the
atmosphere and the oceans
provided almost an infinite
sink, an opportunity for
diluting pollution.
Interesting idea.
So they looked at billions of
pounds of hazardous waste in the
form of these ships and
wondered, well,
what are we going to do with
them?
It's kind of curious what they
did initially.
They decided they were just
going to spray them with water.
So they brought boats alongside
the ships and they started
hosing them off,
assuming that the radionuclides
would somehow wash off into the
sea.
The sailors on the ships
started scrubbing them with
soap.
Then they found that the
nuclides didn't dissipate.
They used solvents.
They started bombing them with
ground up coconut shells.
And nothing seemed to work.
It's kind of interesting here
thinking too that these sailors
are standing on the deck of an
irradiated destroyer with no
protection gear,
absolutely none.
Actually, in 1987,
in the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant explosion,
you see a similar degree of
disregard for worker safety
among those that were brought in
to put the fire out and also to
clean up the mess.
Dramatic misunderstanding on
the part of those exposed,
despite the fact that the
technical knowledge,
understanding the danger,
was pretty well understood
among the people that were
giving the orders to the GIs
here.
So one of the solutions was,
well, let's bury some of it.
We'll just sink some of the
boats that are in the worst
shape,
or we'll find out what parts of
the ship are most irradiated and
figure out what to do with those
pieces.
Kind of an interesting thought.
So you've got this atoll,
which is basically the crater
of an old volcano,
poking out of the Pacific
Ocean, a few strands of beach
ringing it.
You put a hundred ships in
there.
You explode a bomb underwater.
And Michael Oppenheimer,
who was the first director of
the Los Alamos Laboratory,
responsible for the design of
the first atomic bomb that was
tested at Los Alamos in New
Mexico,
Michael Oppenheimer warned very
vigorously against exploding a
nuclear device underwater,
especially within an atoll,
because it would create,
in his words,
a toxic soup that would persist
and contaminate the coral,
it would contaminate the
underlying sands,
and it would contaminate the
water and marine life for
decades.
It would basically make that
fishery no longer suitable for
human consumption.
Quite interesting to see the
moral and ethical arguments
among the physicists who were
responsible for the design of
these weapons back at that point
in time.
Very compelling arguments not
to use these weapons that were
above a specific size.
Oppenheimer and his close
colleagues and friends were
branded as Communists and
communist sympathizers.
There was some legitimacy for
that.
He was a Socialist in his own
political thinking,
but it was quite curious to see
the way the Atomic Energy
Commission attacked him and sent
up spies to follow him and see
who he was associating with.
You can now find this out by
going back into this
declassified documents database.
And then the trials that
eventually were held to remove
him from the Atomic Energy
Commission.
So they've got this waste.
They don't really know what to
do with it.
They began to take some of the
ships and drag them back across
the Pacific to U.S.
ports.
So here is an example of an
aircraft carrier that was
dragged into the port of San
Francisco, called Hunter's
Point.
Anybody here from San Francisco?
Well, you may know this area,
next to the Bayview community.
It's quite an interesting area.
Well, they didn't really know
what to do there.
This was an experiment in
progress, an experiment largely
without controls.
But imagine,
bringing the radioactive waste
into one of the largest cities
on the West Coast that was
surrounded by people and then
trying to remove the radioactive
material from the ship by
sandblasting it.
And sandblasting is a notorious
technology for simply grinding
away at hard surfaces to remove
the residues.
And what happens to it?
Well basically,
it just goes up into the air.
Or if it's foggy or if it's
raining, it'll rain down and
then wash into eventually the
Bay.
Hunter's Point sits on the Bay.
So you can see Hunter's Point
in this map from Google Earth
over here.
And you see the Bayview
District right now,
only probably less than a mile
from Highway 101.
And like many other ports in
the United States,
the port at Long Beach,
port at Newport News,
Virginia, up and down the East
Coast and the West Coast and the
Gulf Coast,
you really find a contaminated
soup of a variety of different
toxic substances,
often in rather close proximity
to very densely populated areas.
So in this case,
it's also quite curious that
this is now the site of a very
active protest.
Many people that live adjacent
to these military sites are
quite concerned about their
exposures.
And it also is the subject,
the target of a renewal effort
in San Francisco,
the San Francisco Redevelopment
Authority,
hopes to take a 14,000-acre
tract of land and redevelop it.
This also happens to be a
center of ethnic minorities in
San Francisco,
especially African Americans.
And these people are quite
concerned that the same
redevelopment effect will occur
at Bayview as occurred in the
Fillmore District when the
government came in,
took over property,
basically forced out tenants
and the poorest in the community
and gentrified it,
dramatically changing the socio
and demographic characteristics
of the area.
So gradually,
by the late 1990s,
we had a pretty good image of
what happened to all of these
radionuclides,
at least in the lower
forty-eight.
So the surveillance was best in
the forty-eight states.
Also in Alaska,
because Alaska was the site of
a variety of underground tests
by the U.S.,
but it also was the recipient
of much of the fallout that came
across from Siberia,
where a number of the Soviet
tests were conducted.
So that the understanding of
the distribution of risk was
really quite sophisticated,
I'd say probably more so than
any other chemical that has been
studied or regulated in U.S.
history.
So that these data were
aggregated by the National
Cancer Institute county by
county.
And you can see the red pattern
indicating areas that residents
received the highest exposure,
measured in milisieverts,
and you also see kind of
unusual patterns developing in
the Northern Rocky region,
but also as far away as
Indiana, Illinois,
and then as I showed you the
other day,
as the cloud had swirled down
from Canada and met a rainstorm
in New England,
the Vermont-New York border as
well.
So this became the foundation
for a rather interesting
compensation scheme on the part
of the government.
So if you lived in specific
states or in specific counties,
you were presumed to have a
certain dose of radiation.
That made you eligible for
compensation at specified
levels, depending upon the
illness that you could
demonstrate.
So you needed a physician's
diagnosis of a particular
illness.
It might be thyroid disease,
it could be thyroid cancer,
it could be leukemia,
it could be bone cancer,
it could be different types of
blood disorders.
It could be genetic mutations.
But if you could demonstrate
that you had an illness that was
plausibly related to exposure to
an array of radionuclides,
it was matched up against this
map so that that became the
formula for a level of
compensation.
The people that lived downwind
are called the down winders,
and $50,000 became available to
those that met the criteria,
that were physically present,
could demonstrate that they had
residency in these areas for
specific periods of time.
The Radiation Exposure
Compensation Act of 1990
provided for compassionate
payments to individuals who
contracted these cancers and
other diseases as a result of
exposure during the testing
period.
And also, for those that were
mining uranium that became the
predominate fuel that was
enriched to produce the nuclear
fuels,
those that mined the uranium,
but also those that
transported,
so that the miners and the
transporters were well
recognized as anther
occupational group that
experienced high levels of
exposure as well as elevated
incidence of disease when
compared to individuals that had
received lower doses of
radiation.
So a payment of 75,000 was
available to people that were
on-site participants,
in other words,
they were actually stationed
there.
The military officials that you
saw with the goggles sitting in
the lawn chairs with the shorts
on or those on the decks of the
cruisers,
or those that actually were
involved in moving into the
region and working on the boats
and trying to figure out what to
do with the mess.
So those that had participated
in restoration efforts also were
eligible.
Here's an example of a uranium
mine worker spending a good
amount of time underground and
being dosed at a really
significant level on a routine
basis.
So $100,000 was available to
those that had been employed,
either above ground or below
ground,
if the mines were located in
certain states and if they had
worked at any time during the
period beginning in 1942 and
then ending in 1971.
So this is kind of interesting
to me, because it really is an
example of the government saying
well, here's a trade off.
You know, we really need to
conduct this test.
We know that these damages are
likely to accrue.
Let's develop a scientific
foundation for understanding the
probability of the causal link
between the exposure and the
adverse health effect.
And we've got to figure out a
way of compensating these
people.
That this is an approach
Congress thought would subvert
class-action lawsuits and they
were largely right.
My nephew is an example,
works for the Justice
Department.
And he works on Native American
claims for those Native American
communities that were believed
to be intensely exposed.
So he goes to the community,
he interviews people using a
fairly extensive survey form.
He tries to figure out their
medical condition.
This is especially problematic,
you can imagine,
for impoverished groups,
because they do not have
adequate medical care.
So that they also,
given the absence of routine
care,
it's very common for the
poorest in society to develop
illnesses that progress until
they're quite serious before
they are diagnosed.
So the wealthier in most
societies have access to medical
care that allows for early
diagnosis,
early treatment,
so that the ultimate damage is
often less among the wealthy.
It was a political science
professor who was trained at
Yale and argued in an article
that being richer is being safer
in the world quite generally.
So that the richer have higher
educations, they have a higher
capacity to understand risk.
They have also a higher
capacity to take action to
manage risk.
And in the event of damage,
they either are able to receive
compensation from insurance
policies that they paid for or
they have the opportunity to go
out and seek high-quality
medical care.
It's an interesting kind of an
argument.
So "Richer is Safer,"
written by Aaron Wildavsky,
who was a rather famous
political science professor at
the University of California.
So what's happened in terms of
these compensation efforts?
The down winders,
those that simply lived in the
area,
have now received about
$600,000, or excuse me,
$600,000,000,
about 12,000 different claims
have been approved.
The on-site participants have
been awarded about $91,000,000.
The uranium miners and the
millers have received about
$600,000,000 and the ore
transporters about $24,000,000.
So a total of about 20,000
people have been compensated at
a level of $1.3 billion.
Now, back up and think.
Well, how many people actually
were exposed during this period
of time?
Well, the Cancer Institute did
an estimate, which was rather
revealing.
By studying tissue samples from
around the world,
their estimate by the
mid-1990s, when the total world
population was roughly 5.6,
5.7 billion people,
their estimate of those exposed
was 5 billion people in the
world exposed.
So any sort of a compensatory
scheme such as this would have
to set boundaries,
would have to set limits.
And our limits were set at our
national border despite the fact
that we contaminated tracts of
land in different parts of the
world.
And it was not as easily
predicted as you might imagine,
given the role that climate
played relative to the
intersection of the rainstorms
with the dust clouds.
And also the long residency
time of the radionuclides in the
atmosphere.
So that Mexico,
Canada, parts of Europe,
were very heavily exposed,
but they did not have any
compensation scheme in place.
Now I'd like to switch gears
for a moment and talk briefly
about medical experimentation.
And you may recall from earlier
history courses that the
Nuremberg Trial in 1946 produced
eventually consensus about
ethical guidelines for human
experimentation.
Well, the Nazis were quite
active at experimenting on
humans and violating most
principles that now have been
adopted by nations or among
nations,
and also principles that have
been adopted by medical
associations around the world.
So the Nuremberg Trial was
conducted in reaction to
horrific experimentation without
seeking consent,
without providing knowledge
about what the purpose was,
what the risks might be,
without anesthesia.
So that there was no sense of
what the humanitarian benefit
might be.
And also, kind of raising a
rather interesting question,
when you think about medical
experimentation,
how should you conceive of the
locus of the balancing that
would go on?
You know, a fundamental
principle of medicine is the
first principle is do no harm.
Well, experimentation may do
harm.
If you conduct a clinical trial
using a new drug,
or you wonder about a new
technology,
such as a nuclear weapon or
exposure to waste from a nuclear
reactor,
then you need to think about
what the net benefit to the
person might be.
Is it okay to think about this
question as one where the
individual that is exposed
deliberately in the experiment,
whether or not the net benefit
should be balanced against the
individual damage.
In other words,
is it ethically responsible to
think that a collective benefit
in terms of making the world
safer,
if you believe that,
by experimenting with nuclear
weapons and trying to figure out
what our resiliency would be,
does it make sense to balance
that against harm that would be
accrued by the individual?
So that now when we think about
the design and license of a new
drug,
we construct the calculus of
good versus harm at the level of
the individual as opposed to at
the level of society.
So for years,
I debated with chemical
industry officials about the
ethical nature of claiming that
it's okay for us to be exposed
to pesticides in food and
drinking water or the farm
workers breathing the fumes in
the air as a plane flies over.
There's a case that we'll talk
about more next-- over the next
couple of weeks.
Is it okay to justify that
based on the claim that well,
you know, if you use
pesticides, then we're going to
produce a lot more food in the
world?
So that we'll avoid starvation,
we'll avoid diseases.
So that's an example where you
conduct the calculus at a very
gross scale,
saying yes, the population is
exposed to these chemicals at
relatively low levels in
drinking water and food,
occupationally at a higher
level.
But it's really worth it,
because we want to balance that
over the net collective benefit
of having a nutritious and
sufficient food supply.
So that these are the basic
questions that were addressed in
the Nuremberg trial,
but also surround the question
about how to manage compensation
efforts.
So twenty-three medical doctors
were on trial for murder,
torture, and other atrocities
performed in the broad name,
in their testimony,
of medical science in
concentration camps.
Now, in response to this,
the American Medical
Association eventually adopted
guidelines that included these:
voluntary and understanding
consent of the subject,
prior animal experimentation,
appropriate medical
supervision.
Those treated were expected to
accrue some benefit or there
should be some overwhelming
humanitarian purpose that's
served if the benefit would not
be accrued by the individual.
So thinking about these
guidelines and then thinking
about the Atomic Energy
Commission's approach themselves
to experimenting with humans is
an interesting topic.
And if you go back and take a
look at the Department of Energy
files,
which you can do on their
website if you simply take a
look at the release of documents
that occurred during the 1990s,
many of which had been
classified, you'll see a whole
array of experiments.
Here's an example of isotope
injections at Brookhaven
National Lab,
where the individual being
injected had no knowledge of
what he was being injected with.
No understanding of the
radioactive tracers that were
being used to understand how
these compounds get distributed
in the body.
So I mean, one of the concerns
at that point in time was,
we're releasing this
technology, we're creating all
these new radionuclides,
how do they behave inside the
human body?
Well, we all know that
radioactive tracers now are used
to track the movement of
different pharmaceuticals to the
body to make sure that they can
reach the target organ and
actually cure an illness or a
particular problem,
such as a bacterial infection.
So that being able to
understand the movement of
chemicals through the body,
where they reside,
what their persistence is,
what their metabolic rate is,
how they break down into other
products and whether or not
those are likely to be excreted
by urine and feces or excreted
by water vapor from your breath.
So these are all questions that
are circulating in their minds
and provided in their thinking a
rationale for experimenting on
humans without asking for their
permission,
without telling them the logic
behind it,
and with no presumption that
the individual would benefit
from that exposure.
So eighty-one studies were
conducted that involved
children's participation or
participation by pregnant women
in radiation research.
Twenty-one of these were
supported by federal funds
determined to be
non-therapeutic.
In other words,
no benefit would accrue to the
individual that participated.
Now also think about this and
think about the logic of
employing children and whether
or not it is reasonable to
assume that a child would have
the capacity to understand the
nature of the risk,
to understand the perceived
humanitarian benefit of
participating in the research,
and also to be capable of
self-monitoring for
physiological effects that might
be associated with the
exposures.
So by the way,
we fall down in this
expectation that children
somehow should be capable of
understanding risks via
education or via product
labeling.
Whereas, there are 80,000,000
children in the United States
today that really have quite
limited capacity to understand
the nature of the kinds of
environmental threats or
environmental health threats
that we've been discussing so
far in the course.
Now that to me is quite
interesting.
If you choose to educate or to
label as a management strategy
to contain risk or to manage a
technological hazard or
pollution --
another good example of that
would be the way we manage
mercury in fish.
We don't set a limit for
mercury in fish and then take
mercury, or take the fish that
are contaminated beyond the
limit out of the marketplace.
Instead, what do we do?
We post signs on the side of a
riverbank or on the side of a
lake, and assume that that sign
is going to be sufficient as a
warning device.
Do not consume more than X
amount of fish taken from this
river, the logic being to
contain their mercury exposure.
So the idea that you've got a
large proportion of the public
that is either illiterate,
that is not technically
competent in order to understand
the technical nature of the
warning,
or not capable of managing
their own health in response to
an adverse event.
So here are a couple of
examples of the way that the
Atomic Energy Commission was
thinking about this.
Here, the AEC medical advisor
is recommending the suppression
of evidence of plutonium
injections.
So not informing people that
are part of experiments.
"There are a large number
of papers (he argued) that do
not violate national security,
but do cause considerable
concern.
Papers referring to levels of
soil and water contamination
surrounding AEC installations,
idle speculation on the future
genetic effects of radiation,
and papers dealing with
potential process hazards to
employees are definitely
prejudicial to the best
interests of the government.
Every such release is reflected
in an increase in insurance
claims,
increased difficulty in labor
relations,
and adverse public
sentiment."
Very, very curious.
So they're arguing that a logic
for secrecy, a logic for not
seeing informed consent is that
it's going to make their life
tougher.
You could use the same argument
to basically scuttle a
surveillance system.
So basically argue,
well, let's not monitor where
this stuff goes,
because if we do then
somebody's going to find out
about it and it could be used
against us.
It could foster public opinion
that would cause Congress to
react to their constituency and
argue,
gee, you know,
we shouldn't continue with this
testing program.
So they're very deeply into
this line of logic trying to
figure out how they can maintain
public support,
but how the very act of
conducting surveillance or
environmental monitoring could
undermine their long-term plans.
In another example,
at Vanderbilt Hospital between
1945 and 1947,829 pregnant women
were fed radioactive tracer
cocktails.
Another at the University of
Tennessee at the College of
Medicine and the John Gaston
Hospital,
two African American women ages
twenty-two and thirty-three were
administered iodine-131 while
they were nursing infants four
months in age.
And both mothers had been
diagnosed with thyroid cancer.
This is curious.
You take mothers that had
thyroid cancer and you would
dose them with iodine,
which lodges in the thyroid,
that had been irradiated.
Infants continued to nurse,
and levels of iodine-131 were
monitored in the mothers' breast
milk and thyroid,
and the infants' thyroid.
The infants' accumulation of
iodine-131 in their thyroids was
significant,
prompting the researchers to
warn against administration of
iodine-131 to lactating women.
So the thinking here that they
understood clearly that the
nuclide moved from mom to the
young,
to the kids via breast milk,
but they really had no concerns
about what the long-term health
effects might be on the women.
At Harvard, Boston University,
and Massachusetts General
Hospital,
there was an experiment
conducted on what they then
called mentally retarded
children in 1961 at the Wrentham
State School.
And it was designed to
understand whether
nonradioactive iodine could
block thyroid uptake of
radioactive iodine,
or iodine-131.
The National Institute of
Health, the Atomic Energy
Commission,
and the Quaker Oats Company
also conducted a similar study
at the Walter Fernald School in
Massachusetts,
also described by the AEC as
being a school for the
"mentally retarded."
And the children were fed
breakfast food containing
radioactive iron and calcium.
The Quaker Oats Company?
Now that's interesting.
Quaker Oats was extremely
concerned about contaminates
moving into their processed
foods.
And they were also worried
about whether or not they might
be able to block the uptake of
some radionuclides by fortifying
some of their foods with other
nutrients.
So could you put calcium in
oatmeal, and would that have an
effect?
Well, perhaps that's an
interesting study.
Perhaps you would want to carry
that study out on animals before
you conduct it on children.
And why would you choose the
Wrentham School or the Fernald
School as a locus of this type
of study?
So nine boys between ten and
fifteen years in age and one
twenty-one year old served as
subjects.
And they were divided into two
groups,
one receiving intravenous
injections of calcium-45,
and the others received it
orally in their breakfast
cereals.
And they were trying to figure
out where this went in the human
body and what role it played in
blocking uptake of other
nuclides.
And several letters were sent
to the parents of the students,
who would become members of the
Science Club if they agreed to
participate.
So the first appeal was made to
the students,
would you like to participate?
And it's kind of interesting to
think about the letter that was
sent to the parents,
so I'm going to read this to
you.
It gives you some insight into
their thinking and their
methods.
"Dear Parent:
In previous years,
we have done some examination
in connection with the
nutritional department of the
Massachusetts Institute of
Technology with the purposes of
helping to improve the nutrition
of our children and to help them
in general.
And for checking up on the
children, we occasionally need
to take some blood samples which
are then analyzed.
The blood samples are taken
after one test meal which
consists of a special breakfast
meal containing a certain amount
of calcium.
(No mention of the
radionuclide) We have asked for
volunteers to give a sample of
blood once a month for three
months,
and your son has agreed to
volunteer,
because the boys who belong to
the Science Club have many
additional privileges.
They get a quart of milk daily
during that time,
they're taken to a baseball
game, to the beach,
and to some outside dinners,
and they enjoy it greatly.
I hope that you have no
objection that your son is
voluntarily participating in
this study.
The first study will start on
Monday,
June 8, and if you have not
expressed any objections,
we will assume that your son
may participate."
Interesting.
So first, the presumption that
they would legitimately ask the
child before the parent.
The presumption that if they
heard nothing back from the
parent, who might be traveling
or whatever, that they would go
ahead with the experiment.
So these studies,
once they were released and
came to the attention of the
Department of Energy and
President Clinton in 1995,
led the administration to issue
an executive order on
declassification.
So during the 1990s,
the Clinton Administration was
responsible for declassifying
almost 400,000,000 pages of
material.
Twenty percent or so reduction
in the total backlog,
but the new classification
programs have been initiated by
the CIA,
the National Security Agency,
and the National Reconnaissance
Office.
So that this period between
1990 and 2000 was a period where
we were declassifying more than
we were classifying.
And following 2001,
September 11th attack on the
World Trade Center,
we've clearly gone in the
opposite direction.
The Department of Energy was
extremely embarrassed by the
release of these studies.
And the former Secretary,
Hazel O'Leary,
undertook what she called an
Openness Initiative in 1993 and
went back through all of her
records of the Atomic Energy
Commission.
And once that was transformed
into the Department of Energy,
the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission, and declassified a
large amount of information.
The National Security
Administration is now the
largest intelligence agency in
the world.
And it is important to know
that they have power to classify
at all levels.
And they also are exempt from
the federal Freedom of
Information Act,
which means that you cannot
request any information from
them.
Or they have the ability to
make the judgment to decline any
request and not give you any
reason for that.
So last year,
we spent-- this is actually a
year and a half old now,
we spent almost $25 billion on
Secret Programs.
Secret programs for
surveillance,
for containment,
technologies to eavesdrop via
computer reading emails,
also watching the way that
people surf the internet.
So that the surveillance
efforts on the part of the
government that remain
classified have never been
higher in human history.
So let's pause and reflect over
the past couple of lectures and
think about some of the key
lessons.
One lesson that is extremely
important,
and I hope five years down the
road,
if you have- if I have any hope
of you remember anything about
this course,
I want you to think about one
issue.
And that is,
if you want to manage the
environment, you've got to think
a lot about the principle of
persistence.
How long does a danger persist?
How is it distributed?
How does it move through the
environment?
The atmosphere,
the water, the soils,
and the food?
And I'm struck,
I'm really struck by the
importance of food as being a
primary route of exposure to
many of the radionuclides in
this case.
But it's also the primary route
of exposure to many pollutants
and other synthetic chemicals in
the food supply today.
I gave a lecture yesterday
afternoon on regulation of food
in the United States,
and I came to the conclusion
that food is often the
predominate route of exposure.
And you often need to think
about controlling air pollution
because of how it might get into
the food supply.
So really, the strontium-90
story, the iodine-131 story,
and also the cesium story as
well, is one about air
pollution.
It's about having the idea that
it's okay to release this
material to the environment and
that it's not going to come back
to haunt us in the form of water
pollution or air pollution.
But where it seems to pose the
greatest amount of threat,
where it concentrates the most
is in the food chain.
So if it gets into the
atmosphere, it's likely to get
into every other compartment of
the environment,
and then it's likely to
boomerang back to us in the form
of a food contaminate.
This case demonstrated also the
length of time,
the enormous amount of science
that needed to be conducted in
order to figure out what happens
to these chemicals in the human
body.
Yes, you could think from a
medical researcher's perspective
that it was legitimate to think
about the need for human
experimentation to figure out
where these compounds go in the
human body and also to think
about the need for long-term
medical surveillance to figure
out what the effects of exposure
at different doses might be.
But there are experimental
guidelines that you could now
imagine that you would want in
place before the government
would have authority to conduct
those types of tests.
This is a case,
probably the best case in the
history that we've got,
the history of environmental
science,
about expert understanding of a
dose-response relationship,
understanding what dose posed a
specific threat.
And also, it is perhaps the
first case in the United States
at least,
where we had an understanding
that these chemicals behave very
differently in the fetus.
They behave very differently in
people that have different
genetic characteristics.
They behave differently in the
young compared to the old,
and that they concentrate in
different parts of the body at
different ages.
So this idea of susceptibility
that now has become a hallmark
of U.S.
environmental law and really a
fundamental principle of
European environmental law,
looking and thinking about
everybody as not being average
but looking at differences in
physiology and these other
characteristics.
Susceptibility is now an
extremely important factor in
thinking about risk,
and therefore becomes a
critical foundation for thinking
about different risk management
strategies,
like setting levels for
allowable contamination in air,
food, and water.
Don't forget in this case as
well that this entire history
took place between '46,
1945, actually,
the first test,
and 1963,
when the atmospheric testing
stopped by the Limited Test Ban
Treaty.
So in this compressed
eighteen-year period.
What environmental laws did we
have in place to control
exposure?
We had nothing.
We had no Clean Air Act,
we had no Safe Drinking Water
Act,
we had no Toxic Substance
Control Act,
we had no Superfund Act to try
to figure out what to do with
these highly contaminated sites.
We had no Food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act that
looked at radionuclide levels in
different foods.
We had no Food and Drug
Administration that might be
responsible for looking for
radionuclides in different types
of foods.
We had no understanding of
whether or not the chemicals
bio-concentrated during the
process of taking a raw corn and
turning it into corn oil or
extracting the water out of a
grape to make a raisin.
So that none of this regulatory
authority existed during this
eighteen-year period.
So at the same time,
what we'll see over the next
several weeks is that this
history is extremely important
in providing a paradigm for
understanding environmental
quality and the distribution of
pollution that was picked up and
was dropped into food safety
law,
dropped into air quality law,
dropped into thinking about
hazardous materials management.
So it's become a very important
component of environmental law.
Also later in the term,
when we think about the current
status and the future of nuclear
power,
we're not going to move into
this discussion too deeply
today,
but I want you to think about
the similarity between what we
learned by 1963,
and then what we learned from
the Chernobyl event.
So, Chernobyl is a nuclear
reactor located just outside of
Kiev in a little village called
Pripyat.
And it exploded and it caught
on fire.
And the roof blew off of it
back in 1986.
And I don't know,
well let's see,
1986, I suppose that most of
you would not have been alive in
1986, but your parents would
remember this.
And you are walking around
probably still with
radionuclides in your body that
resulted from your intake of
foods that were contaminated as
the amount of material that
reached the atmosphere also went
into global circulation,
also rained down around the
world and exposed almost
everyone at a lower level than
was experienced during the
atomic weapons testing era.
A couple of key points of
comparison here.
One is that the expectation on
the part of the Soviet
government,
then responsible for managing
this site,
was that they needed to manage
and test for contamination in
close proximity to that site.
They were most worried about
getting people out of that zone
by evacuating them out within
roughly about a ten to fifteen
kilometer radius.
If you remember that donut,
remember the donut that I had
up there surrounding the map in
Nevada that demonstrated the way
that the Atomic Energy
Commission had similarly
underestimated the movement of
radionuclides.
The same happened here.
Gradually, after they expanded
their testing,
they found that the eventual
distributional pattern is
designated by the red on this
map as the most intensely
contaminated zone.
So if you look at this,
you see that certain of these
zones were confiscated.
Some were confiscated even more
than 150 miles away from the
site of the fire.
There is a very important story
here about the absence of
surveillance leading to a
perception of environmental
purity.
So that gradually over a period
of time,
you know, as the Soviet Union
collapsed and the amount of
surveillance expanded,
the quality of the testing got
better,
they realized that these
nuclides had seriously
contaminated a huge tract of
landscape in the eastern
European nations.
And they basically made
agricultural productivity
impossible.
They made future forestry in
this area impossible.
The forests surrounding Kiev
now have taken up the
radionuclides.
So if you cut those down and
you build a house of the
material, you basically would be
exposing you,
yourself or your family,
to the material.
Or if there is a serious forest
fire in that region today,
and there's been about a six or
seven year drought in eastern
Europe,
so this is a serious concern,
that forest fire would
basically cause these
radionuclides to go back up into
circulation.
Just as on Bikini Atoll,
where they decided,
well, let's restore the site.
Let's take off the top meter or
two of soil, and we'll bring in
fresh soil so that they can grow
crops again.
They still thought that this
would be the effective
restoration technique in the
Ukraine.
But they found that it was an
overwhelming area that had been
contaminated,
3,200 square kilometers,
76,000 square kilometers had
detectable levels of radiation,
and 3,000,000 people lived in
these zones.
So what do you do with it?
What do you do with the
structures that have been
contaminated?
What do you do with the
equipment that's been
contaminated?
In this case,
they decided they were going to
bury it.
So they dug deep trenches and
they buried the military
equipment,
they dug trenches,
they drove the fire trucks into
them and buried the fire trucks,
they buried cars.
So that they basically figured
well, this is one solution to
the problem.
In a slight aside,
it was kind of interesting that
when they would bury the cars,
people would be watching as
they buried the cars,
and then they would go and dig
up the cars and take the car
parts out at night and then sell
the car parts on the black
market.
There's really quite a
similarity here between the
problem of creating hazardous
waste such as this that's been
contaminated by nuclear debris
in Chernobyl and the idea of
creating irradiated hulks of
ships and wondering what to do
about it.
So that once again,
we'll see a kind of a pattern
of denial followed by a pattern
of gradually increased
sophistication and surveillance,
leading to a recognition that,
oh my gosh,
this problem is much bigger
than we thought it was.
So, a few concluding thoughts
about this section.
One is that secrecy is a very
important form of social control
or regulation.
So if we give the government
the right to maintain secrets,
we're giving them the right to
control our knowledge,
to control our intelligence.
And this case demonstrates that
secrecy concentrated knowledge
among those with authority and
power.
It basically inhibits broad
public literacy and
intelligence.
It undermines democracy,
because if you don't understand
these issues,
you certainly are not going to
be an effective participant in
decision making about how to
manage risks.
And these are often pretty
technical decisions.
It prevents accountability.
So the bureaucrats inside the
Atomic Energy Commission or the
Defense Department liked this
part about it very much.
It basically means that they're
not accountable to anybody
except to those that also have
security clearances.
It may restrict individual
liberty, as it has,
restricting rights of 911
detainees.
It can enhance the persuasive
power of elites.
It provides them with narrative
advantage to give their
interpretation of the story,
so if you don't have the
evidence to test or to contest
their conclusions,
you have no political power.
And also, it turns secrets into
extremely valuable commodities.
So in a sense,
secrecy creates intellectual
property.
The more valuable that property
is, the shorter its half life
is.
I'll leave you with one thought
from Albert Einstein.
"It's not enough for a
handful of experts to attempt
the solution of a problem,
to solve it,
and then to apply it.
The restriction of knowledge to
an elite group destroys the
spirit of society and leads to
its intellectual
impoverishment."
Okay, thank you.
Have a good weekend.